You’re sweaty, get chills, and generally
feel terrible.
You, my friend, have a fever.
But, before you reach for the medicine cabinet,
you may want to reconsider breaking it.
Hey there, Kaylee here with DNews.
Throughout the day, your body temperature
can vary depending on the time, your level
of activity, and age, although it averages
to about 98.6 degrees Fahrenheit, or 37 degrees
Celsius.
Fun fact: at night, your core body temperature
drops slightly, allowing you to fall asleep.6
But a temperature over 100.4 degrees Fahrenheit,
or 38 degrees Celsius, usually means that
you have a fever caused by infections or an
illness.5
Fever, also known as pyrexia, is an important
part of the immune system’s response to
an invading bacterium or virus.
The immune system produces pyrogens, which
travel through the blood to the brain, finally
reaching the hypothalamus, the body’s thermostat.2
This then raises the body’s temperature
above the normal range, and, lo and behold,
you are lying in bed, covered in blankets,
fondly remembering the times when you felt
normal.
If you’re really uncomfortable, you might
decide to take an antipyretic, or fever-reducing
medication.
This will inhibit the enzyme cyclooxygenase
and reduce the level of prostaglandin E2 in
the hypothalamus.9 In plain English, the medicine
overrides the signals that tell your hypothalamus
to elevate your body temperature and will
reduce it instead.
But having a fever is actually a good sign!
It means that our bodies are beginning to
fight off the infection.
Previously, scientists believed that the elevated
temperature might inhibit the growth of some
viruses or bacteria and potentially even kill
them.
However, a study published in the Journal
of Leukocyte Biology found that a fever also
helps certain types of immune cells to do
their job better.
In the study, researchers injected mice with
an antigen and then monitored the activation
of a type of lymphocyte called CD8+ cytotoxic
T cells, which are capable of killing cells
infected with viruses and even cancer cells.
Half of the mice’s body temperatures were
raised 2 degrees Celsius while the other half
was left alone.
The results showed that the mice whose temperature
was raised had more of the CD8+ T cells than
the control mice.1 3
This suggests that elevated body temperature
may enhance the function of the immune system,
meaning that we can get better faster.
If left untreated, a fever will normally only
last two or three days, but the duration can
vary.7 8 So, as uncomfortable as it is, you
may be better off not taking any medicine
to reduce it.
HOWEVER, it is important to note that this
is only recommended for mild fevers.
If your body temperature is over 108 degrees
Fahrenheit, you may be in trouble.
If it becomes too high, you’ll definitely
want to go see a doctor.
Fevers from infections rarely get this high,
and are instead usually caused by heat strokes.
See, when your body temperature gets high,
you sweat to cool down.
As a consequence, your body loses water and
salt, which are essential for normal functioning.
And if you’ve already lost a lot of water
and become dehydrated, you may not be able
to sweat fast enough to dissipate the heat,
causing your body temperature to rise even
further.
You know how your parents always tell you
to stay hydrated when you are sick?
Yeah, that’s why.
At such a high temperature, proteins and cell
membranes, especially in the brain, can be
destroyed or malfunction.
Heart muscle cells and blood vessels can break
down, damage can occur to internal organs,
and, in the worst case, a fever can cause
death.4
While a fever may help you get over your infection
faster, the brain and body can only handle
so much.
What’s the worst fever that you’ve ever
had?
And what do you normally do to get over it?
Let us know in the comments and if you want
to know more about temperature’s effect
on sleep, head over to my personal channel,
Explorium, to find out if sleeping naked is
better
for you.
If you’re on mobile, it will be the first
link in the description.
Thanks for watching DNews and subscribe for
more!